it's here the 2016 Bentley VIN tag oh
this is the SUV we've all been hearing
about since 2012 four years of rap stars
singing about how they can't wait to get
one and Bentley executives promising the
most exclusive SUV ever made
this is a 6.0 litre w12 behemoth
complete with 600 horsepower and 663
foot-pounds of torque and it has a
four-wheel drive 8-speed automatic
transmission it'll go to 60 miles per
hour in four seconds and hit a top speed
of 187 miles per hour the Buteyko gets
12 percent better gas mileage over any
of Philly's other models but forget all
that this thing is posh and that's
what's really going to blow your mind it
comes with a choice of four or five
seats you can choose from 15 different
colors of leather plus dozens of
combinations of exotic wood and gleaming
trim there's a Breitling turbine clock
on the dash plus an 8-inch crystal clear
touchscreen and infotainment system the
unmistakable bitly diamond stitching is
everywhere including inside the ski
hatch the exterior has sharp aggressive
features like four brilliant LED
headlamps hung near the large diamond
matrix grow there's a panoramic window
that covers 60% of the roof silver
leather bees are incorporated all over
the place and yes as you might imagine
the bill is going to be about as big as
the SUV itself expect a base model been
taken to cost you more than $300,000
deliveries begin early next year